[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
it's sunday morning and another great
day for football welcome to the squad
ride
live in the bleacher report app brought
to you by our friends at draftkings
look last week the new england patriots
rushed for 250 yards but unfortunately
for the squad ride
rex burke had scored a bunch of
touchdowns and not cam newton as we
hoped
more importantly we wish cam newton the
tennessee titans
the minnesota vikings and all those
affected by a rece the recent outbreak
a speedy and full recovery earlier this
week we asked you who's a lot to score
touchdown in week four we have some
great options here
we're gonna choose three of our favorite
pitches to be featured in week four
check the board all kinds of talent
there
so we have a lot of time to make our
decision along for the ride and to help
you decide we have our betting expert
kelly stewart
and bringing that big nick energy greg
ivory
greg's gonna be in the comments giving
away hoodies because he's always in a
generous mood on a sunday morning
so shout out to ug money and as a
special bonus
our friends from draftkings are gonna
boost the odds
on whatever pick we choose for the squad
run
in week four thank you very much for
that all right so listen we're all
putting a few bucks down so choose
wisely
we need to stack these stacks before we
get to our three pitches
let's take a look at the highs and lows
from week three
run the play action he scrambles doesn't
happen
my lock of the week is the tennessee
titans first half
minus one darren wallace james robinson
could play
[Music]
my locker tonight is lamar jackson i
think it's gonna be a shootout between
the quarterback
the ravens over six and a half points in
the first
quarter the over 54 points is an
absolute
lock he's guaranteed a score touchdown
lock it up make it happen
[Music]
pure joy i love you just i just can't
get enough of it
hey a lot of those guys was uh featured
on the story
riding with me on the story this past
week
that ravens in chiefs game yeah yeah we
were riding on a whole bunch of things
ravens and chiefs uh we've been riding
on nba
but uh we're also riding after this so
make sure you guys tap into the br story
after this today we are right dean
i need winners only please
we do need winners like coach singletary
once said for the niners um okay so it's
time for our first of three pitches
at matt underscore kim is going to try
to convince you to follow his lead in
week four
matt kim what do you have for us my man
oh uh so yes uh wait comments kanji
money
how are they reacting in the comments do
we have any fire fire hot cakes
of course my guy i got you cabbie
in the comments they're saying all type
of stuff
d style is saying it's well with my soul
by getting a hoodie
i guess i guess we're gonna get well
with your soul and we're gonna send you
a hoodie d
style um we got uh john
schneider he said yo hit me with the
sweatshirt guess what john
i'm going to hit you with a sweatshirt
you're going to walk away with a hoodie
cabbie i don't know i'm feeling real
generous no no no no no no no that's the
way it looks
i love in the comments greg how come you
didn't tell him i all i keep seeing is
all the love for kathy in the car kelly
tell him tell him kelly appreciate it
let's get to our first pitch i do
appreciate that but matt kim has got it
he's got a
he's got a a player that he feels is a
lock in week
in week four matt kim what do you got
for us my man
all right this week i got caller murray
to score a rushing touchdown on the
ground
uh he's been killing defenses all year
and he already has four rushing
touchdowns in three weeks and where
he's playing against a panthers defense
that's already let up seven rushing
touchdown this year
and also three weeks so i'm looking for
him to bounce back he had a rough week
last week but i feel like this week the
cardinals offense
dominates the panthers let's go k1
our guy's taking a page out of david
fizdale's book take that for data matt
kim brought it
well done sir go ahead g money cabbie
you see that number down there plus 140
i actually
like the value of this pick let me tell
you what this panthers defense
they are they're kind of young they're
kind of young i can kind of see kyler
mary scrambling right
then scrambling left and then scrambling
back right little russell wilson
impression
going up the middle scoring a touchdown
i don't know i can see him walking in
here
but with that being said i do have
deandre hopkins on my fantasy team
i also want to see him sprinkling some
little throws around throwing some
touchdowns his way
so uh i don't know here i don't know how
i'm leaning here
i can see it happening but i kind of
don't want it happening kelly how are
you feeling
you know greg i have a panthers ticket
in my pocket and that has nothing
really to do with kyler murray scoring a
touchdown here
i like this panthers team when it when a
west coast team
has to travel east early on sunday
mornings we know that they don't always
pan out well i think a lot of people
expecting this cardinals team to have a
bounce back this week
i don't know if i see it though i do
like kyler murray to score a touchdown
today those two things don't always have
to correlate
plus 140 i think the odds are a little
short here
so wait is it kelly was that a short
joke
because the dude is listed at 5 10 but
he's really like
gabby i'm like 5-2 i would never make
short jokes okay there fair
so kelly likes the kyler murray pick g
money are the commenters with
with kelly on that one the comments
are all over the place kevin to be
honest
to be honest with you they're they're
they're not even talking about
what we're talking about in fact kelly
are you seeing anything on your end
as far as in the comments uh these
comments these commenters are always
wild i try to stay
out of it uh everybody just wants
hoodies everybody
wants to tell me that kyler murray is
gonna score a touchdown
uh dtb57 you are not getting a hoodie
because i am not always wrong
but uh just for that but shout out to
you i hope you have a great sunday
[Laughter]
salute all right so it's time for some
trivia because it's always alright time
for security and i'm going to give away
a hoodie
uh so um i don't know if you guys know
this or you you probably do but
in when kyle murray was at oklahoma he
also played baseball and he was drafted
by the oakland a's
in 2018 so the question is in 2018
was kyler murray's batting average over
or under
300 dropping over or under
in the comments and somebody is and
we're going to send you a hoodie but
we're going to get to that in just a
second
um we got we have to get back to our
pitches and our guys
c till 2 believes he's got the person
he's got the player that's going to
score a touchdown in week four
see till two give us the goods
i think alvin kamara's gonna score a
touchdown because he's best running back
in the league
uh he's got the best balance in league
and when he scores a touchdown i'm gonna
get the same nose ring as him
alan carter when you score man hit me up
cheers come on is he serious no is he
serious though
oh that's hilarious yo yo hold up wait
wait wait so if we if if he wins he's
getting the bull nose he's getting the
piercing
we have to hook him up with the grill to
go with it you know is this gonna be
like one of those like mikey lock type
type bets where he says he's gonna get a
tattoo and then
doesn't i mean i need to know i'm not
gonna pick this dude unless he's really
gonna do that because that pierce
has got to hurt no no we're we're
definitely gonna follow through with
this but with that being said i mean
alvin kamara he scored six touchdowns
in three weeks i mean he's averaging two
touchdowns a game
i don't see why this stops today kelly i
really don't
do not see why this doesn't continue to
happen i mean he's been killing in
fantasy he's been killing on the field
he's been killing receiving he's been
killing rushing
the ball he's been doing it all for this
saints offense i don't see this not
happening today
in fact i don't know i really like this
one in in the piercing that that has me
uh
has me liking this one even more kelly
what do you think i think that's
absolutely hilarious and i hope he
actually goes through with it because
alvin kumar is going to score a
touchdown today
now i do lean towards the lions here i
didn't get to the window with this team
the same team this lion team too
actually had lots of adversity
this last couple of days really excited
they're going to be playing here but
greg you hit the nail on the head
you said offense who is the saints
offense my
dude alvin kamara he is going to be
first and for foremost on this team if
the saints want to win this game he is
going to
have to score a touchdown today and the
detroit lions rushing defense is bottom
three in the nfl just putting that out
there so two pitches are in
matt kim matt underscore kim pitched
kyle murray to score a touchdown against
the cart
against carolina and c-till two pitched
album camaro to score a touchdown
against the detroit lions both are great
options
where are you guys leading in the
comments let us know before we get to
our third pitch
earlier i asked you about kylo murray
and his baseball days at oklahoma
in 2018 was his batting average over
or under 300. we picked g
money picked two commenters someone's
got the over someone's got the under
someone's getting a hoodie g-money who
do we have
cabbie we got my guy matthew boyle
rocking with the over and we got don
k.a donk i'm not even going to try to
pronounce that but we're just going to
rock with it you guys see it on the
screen
we got donk k.a donk and then we got
matt
donkey dog donkey
okay so uh the correct answer is
under calamari's batting average was 296
in 2018 with oklahoma so badonkadonk
you're gonna get a hoodie to rock with
your badonkadonk congratulations we're
gonna send that out to you
soon and um it's still hoodie season so
i have one more over under question
does a cameo message from hall of fame
quarterback brett favre
cost over or under 300
to get a special custom cameo message
from brett
hi i'm brett favre i love wrangler jeans
and grand t-shirts uh terrible
impression
yeah you promised me you weren't gonna
do that i was i was working through it
in my mind and it was a complete
disaster
ha anyway over on just drop over or
under in the comments
three hundred dollars for for a cameo
message from brett favre
let's get to our uh third and final
pitch
run dmp which i love that handle right
away i feel like i should we should just
give that dude or that person
a hoodie right away but run dmp he's got
the
he believes he's got the secret sauce
and the player that will score a
touchdown to win
week four dk metcalf finding the end
zone
not only once but possibly twice against
this dolphins defense it's going to be a
high scoring game
russell wilson is going to be continuing
to air that ball out and i expect dk
metcalf to eat
dk metcalf in miami why
money twice
twice really twice i don't know about
twice
but dk methcat does have three
touchdowns in three games so he's
averaging a touchdown per game
um i do see this one being the high
scoring game
out there in miami uh russell wilson i
mean he's having
a remarkable year he actually can't get
one
two dk here would i bet it i don't know
uh kelly i know you're leaning towards
miami what are you what are you thinking
oh greg i'm not leaning towards miami
miami was in contention for my best bet
i picked the dolphins plus six i think
the dolphins have a shot to win this
game and i don't even want to look down
at the comments right now because i'm
sure people are telling me
how crazy i am that being said uh
i think tyler lockett probably has
something to say about that now
you did mention dk matt kev has three
touchdowns on the season
i don't know this is gonna be tough i
think this this dolphin secondary is
gonna have to double team
a couple of these guys which leave
somebody open which could be dk metcalf
i don't dislike it
okay okay so so are the commenters are
they roasting our mvp
are they riding with us
i'm passing this one off to kelly kelly
do the honors tell us what the comments
are saying
about dk metcalf not darius garland said
tyler lockett will score his td or steal
his tds i said that too
donkey donk's very happy he got to win
that hoodie not tim tebow
once a hoodie with all the crying faces
you want me to give out some hoodies rob
staying
2004 brett favre cameo and wrangler
jeans
nice you're getting a hoodie just
because cabbie's impression almost
killed me
let's see take the snake you already
have gotten a hoodie i've seen you in
the comments before
let's see big mike nah
i don't really like you guys don't have
very great comments
all right so keep making sure
firefighter
men see mr ivory hook me up with a
hoodie please
shout out to our first responders you
get a hoodie yes indeed
okay so three pitches are in you have
all the information you need
solid choices as always this week are
you rocking with
color murray to score a touchdown
against carolina alvin kamara to score
a touchdown against detroit or dk
metcalf to score a touchdown
in miami now it's on you to decide our
week four squad ride we're two on one
this year so we need a bounce back
like the vegas raiders drop your
favorite pic go ahead
i was going to say we definitely got to
bounce back because uh
they gave us a little heat last week but
we're we're all right we're
we're back baby we're back and we're
bouncing back today
absolutely and our friends at draftkings
are boosting the odds on whatever you
pick
so while we tally the votes i asked you
earlier and kelly
teased it about about brett favre so
does a
cameo message from hall of fame
quarterback brett favre
cost over or under 300 greg picked two
people from the comments
someone's on the over someone's on the
under someone's getting a hoodie
immediately
g-money who do we got cabbie we have
my guy go white socks he's rocking with
the
over and we have ryan gilmore88
he's rocking with the under
go white sox that's tough the entire al
central out of the mlb playoffs
a conversation for another show and
another day uh
the correct answer is over
it is four hundred dollars to get a
custom message from brett
ha do you know how many pairs of
wranglers that's right
that's probably like ten pairs right
eight or ten bears probably
[Laughter]
so congratulations to go white sox you
are getting a hoodie sorry about your
team
um so we appreciate you we're gonna send
you that very soon we appreciate the
whole squad watching
so stick with us every week same time
same channel we have
more br hoodies to give away uh now it's
time for the big reveal
the votes are in in week four we are
riding with
alvin kamara to score a touchdown in
week four
minus 225 and thanks to our friends at
draftkings
we are boosting those odds give me that
flame emoji
[Music]
to purchase 300. there ten bucks
shout out to see till two with the
winning wager
we need to see that bull ring homie
thank you so much for that
so the winning bet is alvin kamara and
before we go
i know you want that action and she's
here to give you that action
our mvp kelly stewart what is your best
bet in week four
i cannot wait for you guys to roast me
in these comments
afterwards now i know all of you guys at
home
love to bet those little road favorites
they just look so easy and who looks so
easy this week that's right
the 3-0 bills who almost lost that game
got a phantom pi call to somehow pull
out the w
against the la rams last week where was
their downfall
that's right they couldn't stop the run
josh jacobs is gonna have himself a day
today here in las vegas i know there's
no fans
but this team gets amped up as we saw on
that primetime game versus the saints to
play here at home the raiders
plus three and a half the raiders on the
money line
all right kyle's well done so get in
your draftkings app make that bet if
you're rocking with our mvp was about 90
minutes before game time
fewer games this week so make them count
y'all um
congrats to all of our winners congrats
to everybody in the comments
tabby for happy cabbie cabbie
another hoodie let me get in the
comments before we get out of here okay
let me get into the guy niners fans 49
i'll download draftkings right now
if i get a hoodie guess what download it
right now because you're walking away
with a hoodie
we got lee lee shy 21
let me get a hoodie for how bad my
eagles are and when's holding the ball
for 20 seconds every time he gets it
yes i'm gonna give you a hoodie because
the eagles are gonna walk away with a
big l tonight so uh i'm gonna have you
feeling a little good about yourself and
i'm going to let you walk away with a
hoodie cabbie i'm not
done here we go i got ryan b12 must be
nice to get a hoodie it's freezing out
here guess what ryan i'm gonna warm you
up a little bit
okay i'm gonna give you a hoodie cabbie
i got one more i got one more
not darius garland said bruh i got
robbed
darius garland or um you're not really
darius garden obviously your name says
you're not darius garland but guess what
you're not robbed anymore brother
because
greg is here to save you you are walking
away
with the br hoodie uh cabbie
i think i gave away enough cattle i'm
shocked
how many of these guys actually agree
with me today now i'm scared
okay so hey shout out to you and the
raiders pick we are all going to
sprinkle on that today
uh thank you to all the commenters thank
you to the three
the three fellas who pitched today at
matt kim
um at c2 till
excuse me and run dmv much appreciated
join us next week same time same place
right here in the bleach report app
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
i'm cabbie richards
good luck this sunday and thanks for
joining us let's get it
[Music]
you